it's estimated that our galaxy the Milky
Way has 100 to 400 billion stars and
when you hear a number like that the
obvious question is are there
civilizations on planets that are
orbiting any of these stars and maybe an
even more interesting question is can we
detect any of those civilizations have
they gotten to the level of
technological progress like us that
they're emitting electromagnetic waves
into space that other civilizations like
ours can detect them say hey there's
someone else out there watching
television or using radio or whatever
else they might be doing and so what I
want to do in this video is not answer
that question it's a big open question
we don't know the answer we don't have
anywhere near enough information to
definitively answer that question but I
want to do is come up with a framework
for at least thinking about that
question of way of actually estimating
how many detectable civilizations there
are in just our galaxy and there is a
formula that you may or may not have
heard of called the Drake Equation and
what we're going to do is independently
derive our own version of the Drake
Equation it's going to be slightly
different but it's the same thought
process and in a future video I'm going
to maybe reconcile what we come up with
with the Drake Equation and just so you
know the Drake Equation is named for
Frank Drake who is a professor at
University of California Santa Cruz he
first kind of put some structure around
this problem and that's why the formula
or the equation has his name but the
equation it's not an equation that you
can apply on a daily basis and give
results that you can use to build things
or but what it is is it structures our
thinking around around this question of
how many detectable civilizations are
there in our galaxy now to answer this
question I'm going to start a little bit
differently than Frank Drake did he
starts with the number of new stars that
are born each year and we'll see that
our definitions are actually pretty
close to each other what I want to do
what I want to do is start with the
total number of stars so we're trying to
come up with is I'll call it n and this
is the number of detectable
civilizations number of detectable
detectable civilizations
civilizations in the Milky Way in our in
our galaxy and once again there could be
civilizations look looking back at this
star field right over here this star
right over here maybe it has a planet
that's in the right place it has liquid
water and maybe there's intelligent life
on that planet but they might not be
detectable detectable because they
aren't technologically advanced enough
that they're using electromagnetic
radiation or maybe they just figured out
some other way to communicate or maybe
they're beyond using electromagnetic
radiation you know radio waves and all
the rest to to communicate and so we'll
never be able to detect them we're
talking about civilizations like ours
that are to some degree using technology
not too different than our own so that's
what we mean by detectable so let's
think about that a little bit so I like
to start with just the total number of
star stars in our solar system so let's
just start with I'll call it n star and
asterisks and this is the number of
stars number of stars in our not in our
solar system number of stars in our
galaxy number of stars in the galaxy and
our best guess I said is this is going
to be 100 billion to four hundred
billion stars we don't even know how
many there are some of them are
undetectable in the center of our galaxy
it's just a big blur to us and what we
don't even know what's on the other side
of that and we do we can't even that we
we can't even see all the stars that are
packed into the center so this is our
best guess 100 billion to four hundred
billion stars now obviously it's going
to be a subset of those stars that even
have planets so let's multiply it times
that subset so let's multiply it times
the frequency of having a planet if your
star this is the percent chance or the
the frequency or the fraction of these
plant of these stars that have planets
so I'll write it this way fraction that
have planets that have planets that have
planets so if this is a hundred billion
and that let's say I'm making a guess
here and we're learning more about this
every day there are all these
discoveries of exoplanets planets
outside of our solar
system maybe this is 1/4 then we could
say well that means that they're 2100
billion times 1/4 means that they're 25
billion stars that have planets around
them but that's still not enough to go
to civilizations we also need to think
about planets because the planet could
be a planet like Jupiter and we don't
know how life as we know it can survive
on a planet like Jupiter or a Neptune or
mercury it has to have planets that are
good for sustaining life preferably have
a rocky core liquid water on the outside
that's what we think are the ingredients
that you need for life maybe we're just
not being creative enough that's what we
know is life is being so let's multiply
this let's multiply this times the
average number of of life sustaining or
planets that could sustain life on them
so we don't necessarily that they're
going to have life but they seem like
they're just the right distance from the
star not too hot not too cold they have
the right amount of gravity water all
the other stuff and we still don't know
exactly what this means but this means
average average number so given that
there's a solar system with planets
what's the average number of planets
that are capable of sustaining life
average number of planets capable of
sustaining life sustaining life and once
again we don't know this answer
maybe it's it's point one it's kind of
you know it's probably it's it's it's
it's probably less than one therefore
any given solar system that has planets
the average numbers capable of
sustaining life maybe it's point one
maybe it's more than one I don't know we
don't know the exact answer here but
I'll throw an answer here me I'll throw
out a guess maybe it is zero point one
and here the fraction that have planets
I don't know I'll throw that out is and
once again I'm just making up these
numbers we really don't know the right
answer this is one-fourth but if we were
to multiply this out we would have the
average number of planets in our solar
system that are capable of sustaining
life that are around stars that have
planets and these plants are capable of
sustaining life now and this would give
us a total number because it is average
per solar system that has planets this
is the total number of solar systems
with planets you multiply it out total
number of planets in our gas
Aleksey capable of sustaining life now
just because you have liquid water and
the right temperature and all of the
rest ingredients doesn't necessarily
mean that you will actually have life
happening on your planet so let's
multiply that times the fraction that
actually generate that actually generate
life so this is the fraction that
actually have life and this is actually
a very we don't know this answer so this
is this is a fraction that get that have
life on them have life and this is a
really big open question maybe if you
have the ingredients maybe almost every
planet has life maybe it's a frequent
thing that's happening in our galaxy and
frankly our universe or maybe it's a
very infrequent thing maybe it's just
the right kind of freak set of
circumstances that just have to happen
I'll throw out a number just to just
just for the sake of just to have a
number there maybe it's one out of every
ten planets that have all of the right
ingredients for life actually do
generate life my personal guess it's
probably higher than that given that
life seems such a robust and flexible
thing that we've been seeing in all
sorts of weird circumstances actually
let me make it even a higher number than
that so let me make it one half assuming
that we have all of the ingredients so
this should tell us essentially how many
planets if we were to multiply all of
these how many planets in our in our in
our in our galaxy have had life on them
at some point in the those planets lives
that the life might have come and gone
it may be destroyed itself through
nuclear war whatever but this would tell
us the number of kind of life planets in
our galaxy that have had life on them at
at least one point in their in their
history now we care about civilizations
so let's multiply this times if you make
all of these you even get to the point
that you have life we care about well do
you get intelligent life so maybe if the
asteroid never hit Earth the dinosaurs
would have stayed on earth and they
would have never evolved to the point of
generating radios and TVs and telephones
and all the rest and and and so it's
kind of a freak a circumstance that we
were because they were destroyed these
gaps in the ecosystem developed so that
we could emerge and be intelligent and
do all of these crazy things like make
youtube videos and all the rest so let's
multiply this times the
for action if you get all of this the
fraction that actually end up having
intelligent the fraction that actually
end up having intelligent life and maybe
this fraction is so intelligent life
intelligent life over here so
intelligent life this is maybe I'll
throw out a number 110 then probably the
next video I'll calculate at all and
this is very important to realize
because once again you could have life
these are all examples of life right
over here the exact this is actually
life on our on our planet even though
this looks quite alien this is a weevil
it kind of looked very close up but
there's all sorts of forms of life many
of which we probably can't even begin to
imagine but what we care is that
intelligent life intelligent life starts
to emerge on the planet because only
intelligent life has a chance we believe
of being able to eventually communicate
in ways that are detectable by us now I
said intelligent life but maybe not all
intelligent life will eventually get to
the technological civil sophistication
where they will be using radio waves and
electromagnetic radiation to communicate
with each other you know maybe we might
have stagnated at this stage if nothing
if the right things didn't happen so
what we needed to do now is multiply
this so right here we have we would have
the number of planets in our galaxy that
have had intelligent life on them at
some point in their history maybe not at
a time that coincides with ours what we
want to do is is Whittle it down even
more to the percentage that get to the
point that they can that they can
develop technology that allows us to
detect them so they're kind of that so
let me put it so let me multiply it
times the fraction that our output a see
here for maybe they're using
communication C for communications that
allow us to detect them so this is
detectable the fraction that are
detectable detectable now you might
think that we're done this would give
you the total number of civilizations or
life-forms in our galaxy or the planets
that have life forms that
- detectable technologies at some point
in their history now it would be nice if
if civilizations did not kind of be born
and then die but the reality is they do
die they might destroy themselves or
whatever and they might exist for only a
small period of time for the history of
that planet or the history of that solar
system so in order to make it the number
of civilizations that are that are in
existence now and I'll quote I'll
clarify what now means in the next video
because it's really if we're detecting
something from a star that's 10,000
light-years away our now means we're
just receiving their signals which means
that they release the signals 10,000
years ago but what I want to do is what
is the fraction of these whose signals
are achieving are reaching us right now
and here I'm going to say well what's
the average lifespan of a civilization
I'll put that l who knows what that is
maybe 10,000 years so civilization
lifespan lifespan and it's going to be
that over the life of the star so that
is over I'll put a T here T for the star
so the average lifespan for the star and
I could say the average lifespan for the
planet or whatever but we're assuming
that if you know what's our star
supernovas they're you're not going to
have any chance for Earth to develop
life on it anymore so maybe this thing
up here is ten thousand years and this
down here is maybe ten billion years and
if you were to multiply all of this out
you should get the number of detectable
civilizations in our galaxy right now
I'll leave you there for this video in
the next video we'll discuss a little
bit more and reconcile it with Drake's
with Drake's
the more famous version of Drake's
equation and I'll also try to talk about
this piece a little bit because I think
this might be a little bit confusing and
I'll try to diagram that out a little
bit more